AND HART  --  BRAUN  SHOT.  PUC
PLAYCENTER.
BUT BRAUN GOES PAST A COUPLE OF
PLAYERS AND GETS TO
OVER TO KEVIN HAYES. WRAPAROUND
ATTEMPT.
SLOW TO GET ACROSS.  EICHEL, SH
MADE ITS IT
ENDED UPTAKE THAT.
AND STARTINGBEEN ON HIS
GAME SO FAR.
PUCKS COMING AT HIM FROM ALLAVI
ANOTHER.
AND THEN
RUSH FOR CONNECTING.
DOES A NICE JOB MOVING IT
PACIORETTY, TO THEODORE.
AND THEY ARE SET UP.
THERE ENII DADONOV WILL
GET THE GOAL.
EICHEL.
TO MARCHESSAULT.
GETTING PAST
GOOD LOOK.
>> HE WAS KIND OF HANDCUFFED
BY THE
JACK EICHEL.
NEVER IN
PATRICK BROW
FOR TTING TO EICHEL.
AT THE LINE.
FIRES.
SAVE MADE BY HART.
JUMPS ON TOP OF THE REPIETRANGE.
THEODORE.
BEEN ON THE ICE FOR OVER 25
MINUTES, BOTH IN TIME T CHANDLE
44.1 SECONDS ON THE